good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 606 object class
Euclid Keter classification is under
review special containment procedures
SCP 606 is currently housed of its own
will in an unfurnished twenty by twenty
five by eight meter cell at site the
entrance to which is sealed by two 25
centimetres steel blast doors on either
side of an airlock no personnel are to
enter SCP 606 s containment cell except
under controlled testing circumstances
or with authorization from a staff
member of level four clearance or higher
standard positive action defenses
explosives chemical biological and
mimetic are to be in place at all times
according to standard operating
procedure due to SCP 606 is non
corporeal nature no reliable security
measures in case of a containment breach
have been developed at this time in the
event of such a breach all personnel
should refer to plan ETA 6 through use
of a remotely operated device scp-668
USB flash storage device containing no
less than 2 megabytes of data every 12
hours the data contained on the device
is to be left to the discretion of
scp-668
but text from classic literature or
encyclopedias movie clips or audio files
of historical speeches are ideal in an
emergency situation this may be
substituted with data in any form such
as print compact discs or video tapes a
careful record of all data provided to
SCP 606 must be
kept SCP 606 should not be given
repeated information except in an
emergency situation no material
pertaining to the foundation or other
anomalous objects should be provided to
SCP 606 under any circumstances
description scp-682 eyes and intensity
most commonly it is approximately 85
centimeters in diameter and emits 220
candalas of luminosity but has been
observed to grow up to 10 meters in
diameter and emit over a hundred
thousand candalas SCP 606 has also been
observed to shrink to four centimeters
in diameter emitting less than 0.5
Kandla despite its ability to emit large
amounts of light scp-668 s-- no heat it
does not appear to be composed of any
form of matter and is able to pass
through material barriers effortlessly
it is presently theorized that SCP 606
is an entity composed purely of
knowledge or information and information
obtained from SCP 606 itself appears to
corroborate this furthermore SCP 606
appears to derive sustenance from
information growing in both size and
luminosity when provided with sources of
information to its affer mention maximum
size and shrinking when it is deprived
of this it is capable of feeding off a
large number of different sources
including digital devices books magnetic
tape and living beings which simply
involves SCP 606 surrounding the object
this process does not appear to affect
its sources in any way digital media
stored on flash drive is used in the
maintenance of scp-666 well as
approximate size of all information
provided to SCP 606 may be easily
recorded the specifications for SCP 606
is maintenance listed above have been
formulated through both discussion with
SCP 606 and prolonged observation SCP
606 appears to hold a preference
for classical literature for example and
the given amount has been observed to
keep SCP 606 at its normal size and
luminosity SCP 606 is sapient apparently
self-aware of all knowledge it is gained
over its existence and capable of
intelligent communication it
accomplishes this by producing pure
sine-wave tones through an unknown
mechanism this has been refined through
teaching SCP 606 a tone based language
system of the foundation's own invention
which all personnel of level 2 or above
assigned to SCP 606 are acquired to
learn if another sapient individual
enters SCP 606 is containment cell they
will attempt to enlighten them to use
scp-666 o6 moving to surround the beings
head or similar equivalent this results
in generalized tonic-clonic epileptic
seizures for a period of 30 seconds to 5
minutes after which the individual
lapses into a coma followed by death
EEG monitoring of affected individuals
during this process has shown a massive
increase in activity of all brain waves
particularly gamma and beta type waves
it is presently theorized that this is
the result of scp-668 empting to
transfer all the information it has
gathered to the individuals brain
through an unknown process despite the
normal human brain being unable to
sustain the stress of such a procedure
results of interviews with SCP 606 have
been mixed although it has previously
deigned to answer some basic questions
about itself and its history any more
in-depth questioning or questioning on
the topics it possesses knowledge of
inevitably results in a request by a CP
606 to enlighten the interviewer and a
refusal to answer further questions
requests made to SCP 606 to refrain from
attempting to enlighten without
permission have been partially complied
with SCP 606 no longer tries to
enlighten every individual that comes
into contact with
but it is still sporadically tried to
perform the process without prompting
for this reason access to SCP 606 is
cell is restricted scp-668 on 11th 19th
in France after a rash of missing person
reports was brought to the foundation's
attention personnel subsequently managed
to lure SCP 606 into a transport vehicle
and transfer it to its current facility
by offering it d-class personnel to
enlighten once its noncorporeal nature
was discovered as CP 606 was asked why
it did not attempt to evade capture it
replied that it wished to see what would
occur as SCP 606 is able to pass through
all forms of matter it presumably stays
in foundation custody of its own
freewill
perhaps due to the constant supply of
information provided to it addendum 606
one complex communication with SCP 606
was made possible on february 4th 2005
when dr and completed their work on the
after mentioned tone based language
details of this language were
transcribed onto normal writing paper
and left in scp-616 tainment chamber an
excerpt from a CP 606 his first
interview follows conducted from a
secured monitoring room over microphone
scp-668 a poppy and thus dr. commentary
is in english
this is document 606 1 playing now can
you understand me
how did you learn to do this could you
tell us what you are have you been more
specific
enlighten you I do not wish to do that
at the moment may I ask you more
questions so how old are you could you
explain what you mean by that how do you
enlighten people are you aware that this
causes your students to die what do you
teach do you know Hawaiian Humane for us
and older do you know what a doctor is
it is your one who has been taught
teaches in your own fashion
can you take me through talking to me at
this point
scp-668 the interview and refused to
answer further questions for some days
from doctor subsequent interviews have
gained little more information of
significance on a CV 6:06 or the subject
it claims to know about addendum 606 -
after reviewing the reports on 606 in
particular experiments 606 I'm becoming
increasingly suspicious that the deaths
of its students are not accidental the
possibility that it has some malevolent
purpose completely independent of its
teaching cannot be discounted yes
everybody says that it's just trying to
teach people but all we know is that it
causes them to kneel over and die no
solid evidence for it actually being
what we think it is has been uncovered
we don't even have any way of stopping
this damn thing countermeasures research
should be a top priority for section in
collaboration with the 6:06 staff group
a Keter upgrade must be taken into
consideration dr. major
well looks like some of you need a visit
from SCP 606 anyway that about does it
for today thank you very much for
listening if indeed you still are and
you're all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre bashert
Muslim wookie Jax Marik Pierce M Hamlin
Austin Thomas Aldridge
Desmond Hoskins Depp's McGee doctor
mortis Johnno Porter
Judi Dench Tiber ball on sy7
actual if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you